mais monsieur monsieur le président mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre de la cohésion des
territoires et porte sur les zones de
revitalisation rurale zrr
madame la ministre le 26 novembre 2019
avec mes collègues co-rapporteur
frédérique espagnac et bernard delcros
nous vous avions remis notre rapport
sénatorial portant sur l'avenir d'ee
ederer parmi nos recommandations il y
avait avant tout l'idée de proroger d'un
an et demi soit jusqu'au 31 décembre de
ville 2021 le dispositif actuel afin de
réfléchir à la réforme des critères et
aux mesures financières associées
en réponse nous vous nous aviez dit non
et vous avez proposé une prorogation de
seulement six mois
jugeant que vous aurez en si peu de
temps la possibilité de réformer
l'ensemble des critères de classement
vous deviez également vous inspiré du
travail sénatorial
malheureusement cette réforme n'a pas
encore vu le jour au point
qu'aujourd'hui vous soyez prêtes
selon certaines informations a prorogé
le système actuel jusqu'en 2022 si cela
s'avère être vrai je m'en réjouis mais
je constate que le sénat a de nouveau eu
tort d'avoir raison trop tôt
madame la ministre durant la campagne
sénatoriale tous les élus concernés par
les ederer que j'ai rencontrés m'ont
manifesté leur inquiétude quant à
l'échéance des ederer prévu à la fin de
l'année avec pour interrogation comment
peut-on parler d'un plan de relance
lequel contiendrait des mesures de
relocalisation alors que l'on s'apprête
à réduire encore les ederer qui comme
vous le savez favorise l'installation
des entreprises dans les territoires les
plus isolées alors mes questions sont
sains confirmez-vous la prorogation
jusqu'en 2022
si oui avez-vous élaboré un calendrier
sur l'étude des critères pour vous
répondre
la parole est à la musique
de la cohésion des territoires mon amour
au monsieur le président s'est cassé le
micro monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur rémy pointereau oui le premier
ministre a décidé peut prolonger les
ederer jusqu'en 2022 gelé dit la semaine
dernière à l'assemblée nationale dans
une question d'actualité qui m'avait été
posée oui je me souviens très bien de
d'abord un du travail excellent que vous
avez fait avec frédérique espagnac et
bernard delcros je me souviens très bien
déjà des questions qui m'avait été posée
et je vous rappelle au passage que nous
avions déjà conservé jusqu'à la fin de
l'année toutes les communes qui devait
sortir au mois de juillet vous vous en
souvenez soit 4400 commune sujet le
chiffre en tête peut-être imprécis mais
je crois que c'est cela
mais nous avions dit que vous nouvion
voulions comme vous le recommande y ait
dans votre rapport qui disait que
c'était un caractère complexe et
insuffisamment cibler que les zrr et
nous voulions effectivement à la demande
aussi des maires ruraux et du secrétaire
d'état joël giraud essayer de faire une
géographie prioritaire de la ruralité
plus ciblée mais nous avons jugé le
premier ministre a jugé que le temps
n'était pas assez long pour mettre en
place un nouveau système que la crise du
coc vide comme vous l'avez ou de l'aco
vide que vous l'avez dit à l'instant
pour refaire la relance est très
important tous les conséquences de la
crise du code qu'ovide avec la relance
est très importante donc cette décision
a été prise par le premier ministre et
bien sûr je suppose que cela vous
convient ce qui nous empêchera pas de
continuer à travailler comme nous avons
commencé à le faire notamment avec
l'insee pour définir une nouvelle
géographie dans les années qui viennent
monsieur potro
oui madame louise je me réjouis de cette
cette annonce après l'assemblée
nationale je suis bien sûr tout à fait
heureux de voir que vous allez remettre
en route et ederer mais absolument il
faut que le sénat soit associé le sénat
et la maison des territoires et je pense
que ça serait tout à fait logique que
nous soyons associés à cette réflexion